all right Scott thank you very much good evening
everybody we're almost set for the 275th and final
meeting in this storyed building between the
Detroit Red Wings and the Montreal Canadians
well Chris the first time that Detroit played in
this building now I know you're going to say that
I was at the game but I was not was 69 years ago
this last Thursday night November 30th 1926 they
defeated the Montreal Maroons that was the first
time they played here 4 nothing the goalie was
Harry happy Holmes now the goenda there's been a
lot of pucks into the net between hap Holmes and
Mike Vernon as far as the Red Wings and everybody
else is concerned the first time they played the
Canadians here it was January 18th 1927 Patrick
Ra was not in the Nets I think George Haworth was
and the Canadians won that game [Music] 53 and
now Bob Rose the point in a big collision with
malakov at the line and Play Whistle down the
first penalty of the game is being ass set and
we welcome Greg Millan boy I'll tell you you're
not you're getting in better shape you're not as
breathless in this time as you were about three
weeks ago they told you to get ready thanks to
the players they haven't been a whistle for
a while so the fight and a hooking call right
here will put the Detroit Red Wings on the power
play Valerie breu will get the gate look for the
Red Wings this evening to just use the point on
their power play and jam in front of the net he
leads the Red Wings in Power Play points and an
assists overall better off Larry onov there's
Primo parked in front Larry onov walking in
Patrick ra and he scores on the rebound eigor
larana how about this play by larana great
players have the ability to hold on to the
puck for the extra second a good chance here
by larionov and he does not will buy the net
and just bangs the his own rebound by Patrick W
look at the tremendous Patience by larionov who
follows his own rebound and it just trickles
through by Patrick W and once again patience
he's going high everybody will be going high
on Patrick w we all know he likes to go down
on the butterfly Lana gets a rebound because he
puts the first shot up high and a nice little
present the referee car ra you know it's funny
cuz Greg dorski went over first and he didn't
know what to do with it carry the experienced
referee just grab the octopus let's take another
look at Larry Anna's fifth power play goal of
the year and a good play by federov to take a
hit to make a pass and make the play and keep the
other guy tied up so he can't get back in the play
Bingle nice haircut once again best hair in the
league carry Frasier fov and Coffey assisting on
the goal a 310 power play goal and the Red Wings
with a one- nothing lead sends it ahead and here's
Saku Kyu with Fraser and kuu blast that off the
Stick of berser breat up ahead Head Drop B over by
Constantino larionov sends it deep federov centers
it there's klov the shot and Patrick w got the pad
down on that one and it's flipped over the glass
and out of play Patrick o once again with terrific
look at this lock here Constantino with a great
big hit because the Red Wings lock up the left
side that allows the defense to jump in and be
very aggressive and Koff with a highly skilled
shot on goal almost caught Patrick W here's t
Working into the zone and he can't beat his man
recky picks it up puts it in front and now it's
stand oh can't clear it than play by T walking
in glove stopped by Vernon Eiserman stopped at
the line Tua moves it ahead here's Savage winds
up and Vernon had a piece of that he'll send it
back in as Montreal completes the chain donus is
on the ice with Keenan Petro lead pass to fedro
flying in with the shot the rebound Constantino
shoved it ahead here's constan OV jumping into
the rush Constantino the shot he gets his own
Rebound in the corner as papovich went down
sharp angle federov took a shot lose larionov CL
scor well the Russian connection is certainly
hot so far this first period klof with a gift
and once again Larry Ona boy oh boy does he see
the ice so well a very very alert the Red Wings
just on top of the Canadians half a step or
a step ahead of them pretty well this entire
period simply outworked them he beat them to the
puck all the way on that play great as Barry Smith
and Cofer lindst have been their best def s
and he said you got to put Constantino right
with them look like a red wi penalty here on that
chase for the puck down on the Detroit Z Carrie
Fraser calling an interference penalty and Keith
Primo's doing the arguing so you have to assume he
is being penalized important time here for the
Canadians they're down two nothing early they
have been totally outplayed in this period by a
very efficient Detroit team they've got to get
back to within one if they can here you know this
is the fourth time fellas that the Red Wings have
played back to back against a team that didn't
play the night before terson dancing towards the
line Puck cleared in from the wrong side of
Center but the Canadians do get to it first
here's Savage along the boards back to Malikov
in and taaw side of the net they [Applause]
score [Applause] a terrific play by Malikov
to not shoot on goal but shoot for the tip
ton calls for the puck recky just is right in
the crease and he out muscles everybody to tap
the puck into the empty net but a very very good
play by Malikov to find ton stick by the side of
the crease instead of just hammering it straight
on goal 2-1 Red Wings as Chris Draper dropped for
AO the shot rebound and Patrick W with two
Dandy saves there with the Red Wings leading
[Applause] 2-1 now four checking is klov who
has to goahead go and another
as klov took a shot that hit
something and went into the net I don't know if
it hit feder off but without question he went
right in front of the goal crease and that Puck
sliced off somebody's stick on the way through
and federov watch him he's in the corner in the
left of your screen right through and he's well
maybe not as close to the front as it looked
from our angle yeah I think it hit canel in
front of the goal now Johnson motoring through
Center Greg Johnson trying to bar right through
Puck underneath them and now underneath Patrick
W for a faceof 3-1 Detroit here in the first have
to go down to Frederick so a two-man Advantage
for 4 9 seconds Red Wings haven't scored with
a two-man Advantage yet this year great chance
to change that lrom scores didn't take long did
it now this is the worst first period in home I
for Montreal since that Infamous opening night
when the Philadelphia Flyers had them down
four to nothing it's 4 to1 here now still a
minute 56 to go in the period and still 449
to go in the major penalty this is textbook
five on three watch by rine moves it in low
to Primo copy cheating down Johnson back into
Primo he can't get it out in front gives it
to Johnson Eiserman in front that's cleared by
Canal Coffey keeps it in at the line with now one
minute left I the score again another Power Play
goal that's three for the Red Wings in this
first period Well I don't know the last time
the Montreal Canadians allowed five goals in one
period and you know the only time Scotty Bowman
has coached in this building as coach of Detroit
his team was beaten 8 to one and the power play
continues boys it'll continue through to the end
of this period for about 3 minutes at the start of
the [Music] second klov looking for it there with
Larry anov fov two assists in the first period
back to patis off larionov chips of klov in front
kintel cleared it into the corner with the gaping
net just behind him line kept in there's Larry
on off again batisa cross ice coslo and Patrick
W there to Rob him eyeing seconds of this power
play fatis off better off klov in front there's
the Hat Trick and it's a power play goal there
fourth of the [Applause] night well let's face
it Patrick W has absolutely no chance on this
play but Patrick Wall is going to have to adapt
to the way this big line is playing for the wings
you have to stay in your feet they're passing it
so much that Patrick W is overc committing as he
does here terrific patience once again by Koff
and W is down and out first game of the year for
Conroy just called up from frederickton wearing
number 20 Mike Keane looking to Center here's
a shot in front Kean looking for his first goal
of the year can't beat Vernon great chance for
the captain Brasher along the board pers right
there but comes loose to the point forine
shot cleared by iserman and a breakaway here
for D know in and he scores and what a throw
for the rookie to score here at the Montreal
Bor Patrick W looking over to the bench like
he wants out what a thrill as you mentioned
Dan O scored the last time these two teams
meet met with a great Blast from the side
boards he said he'd love to score on Patrick
La I'm sure he likes it even better scoring
in the Montreal Forum and terrific speed
watch his head it's up all the way in on
Patrick W he doesn't bury it but he misses
the shot and then sort of shovels it through
Patrick W who's backing up but he just fans
completely and oldtime hockey just jams it by
walk now the most goals against
the Canadians in one game this
year seven the first game of the season
by Philadelphia the rngs at seven and
this one's not 25 minutes old last time
they did that this season there was a
wholesale change here's fov whipping it
in and the fans getting on Patrick W who
responds W jestering back at the fans as the
park heads up Bight well he's just done with
that he's just taking the final score off the
front page tomorrow KLA Brink wide there's Rous
we passed the Midway point of the second period
and here's Johnson scoring on a Nifty feed from
Keith Primo 81 Detroit now Scotty Bowman's even
in this building now coaching the red wi he lost
8-1 and now he's leading 8-1 and this game is
barely half over and what a great play by Kei
Primo nine goals in 11 games and Pat Jai is going
to get the equipment wsky has moved down into the
isway behind the Canadians bench to get a goal
stick so A change is in the offing here as Mike
Vernon at the other end hops on the puck Savage
now with dom fous and recky as the shot snapped
in on Vernon they're try all their trick plays
now that one didn't work but fov spins it back
across klof roaring in the drop pass and rcky was
there eight covering eight Lana bov scores 9 one
and the flood gates are open at The Forum and
now we anticipate it's time for Pat jablonsky
you might also anticipate a game in which the
Montreal Canadians allow the most goals against
ever the most is 11 against them and there's
nine [Applause] here you know In fairness to
Patrick w i mean what are he supposed to do
here watch the Canadians once again they're
all chasing facing the puck carrier that leaves
better off wide open in front I mean he's teeing
this thing up he has one the hardest shots in
the league one timer and there's absolutely no
way that Patrick W can stop that Puck and boys
finally here comes Pat chonski and Patrick hey
it's not to your fault get out of there get arrest
and get ready for the next game and forget about
this baby it's over and every Canadian on
the ice went over to tap the pads to Patrick
w [Applause] a rare night indeed at The Forum in
Montreal better off from larano
at 1157 Patrick W just went over
and said something to Cory and I'm
not so sure what it was but he went
right to him that'll be even more of
a story tomorrow possibly hey the PO
Pickens Dand and jatski covers up 735
to go in the second period here at the
[Applause]
four up to K Vu they got the Smurf line back
together but they're offside at the Detroit
line [Music] well the look of ran the Canadian
fairly new general manager tells it all likewise
team President Ronald Cory but drg isn't this
ear it's kind of eerie this is almost like the
first night of the Philadelphia game when the
Canadians got off so badly on the wrong skate
and were down so so big so early and and
does this mean that they are right right
back to where they started the season literally
at game one klof has led the assault with three
goals Larry hov's been brilliant there's
better off coslov has four and what a
goal double figures at The Forum for the Detroit
Red Wings in their final visit well gentlemen
there are times in the Boost when you just let the
pitchers take over I think this is a good example
this is beautiful next game against New Jersey and
Pittsburgh and here they come again coffee with
klov in front primo and jablonsky down centered
in front cleared by T Coffey looking to Center
again against recky puts it in front there's
Primo whacking away at it Center in front Greg
Johnson couldn't find it and he'll have a break
here's fov in a Loa jabloni and a good stop by
jablonski as vov was looking for his sixth
point of the [Music] night welcome back to the
Forum in Montreal where the Red Wings lead the
Montreal Canadians 10 to one after two periods
of play Patrick W was the center of attention
in that second period of play here he reacts to
the crowd and it's jering of him as he made an
easy save in that second period and then later
Patrick was taken out of the game in favor of Pat
jablonsky he went behind the bench he stared down
marot trom then he went back and had some words
to say to the president of the Canadians Ronald
Cory and then Patrick went and took his seat
at the end of the bench as Pat jablonsky went
into the game to play for the Canadians and try
to salvage something uh from what is now a 10-1
lead for the Detroit Red Wings well I'll tell you
what the mood here in the hallway of the Canadians
and they're still behind closed doors waiting to
come out here uh for the third period of play we
got about a minute to go now and the Canadians
are just coming out now and they're led by Pat
jablonsky followed by Patrick w Canadians
are down 10 to one 10 goals have not been
scored against the Canadians in this building
since 1983 and that was when the Boston Bruins
beat the Montreal Canadians so they're way down
tonight and there are ill feelings between the
coach and the goendale Mario any chance we' get a
word with you Mario tromble doesn't want to talk
to us right now anyway Chris back up to you with
Dick Irvin and Greg Millan as the Canadians head
out Scott I'm sure there is going to be a lot
said following this one well I was just in the
Press room and it is hopping dick there's so much
that can happen when a star player and management
or a coach are at odds we saw with eigor larionov
and San Jose he finally left and was traded and we
learned Now Kevin constantina has been dismissed
in San Jose and right now it would seem by the
pictures and happenings in the game tonight
that these two gentlemen very integral in the
Montreal Canadians are at odds through 40 minutes
here well I think fellas the key from a Canadian
standpoint they everybody involved has to say
the right thing that's Mr Cory's seat he may be
upstairs now with raan I don't know but no matter
who's involved in something like this great they
have to they have to calm down they have to get
control of themselves before they it's the quote
start coming and they have to say the right things
on an historic night at the Montreal Forum here's
recky with a shot tuaw reaching for the rebound
jablonsky to distract the second per get him out
of and jablonsky tying it up at the side of the
net pass from fatis off now Constantino hammers it
in on jablonski heiserman to the line with Bob Ary
here's a chance and pop got a stick on it I don't
know how DED never did it here's Steve Eiserman
setting it up Lindstrom and what a fine save
that was by [Applause] jablonsky here's canel at
the point firing it buron with a good save there
and Eiserman clears it down the ice starts back
for Detroit with drg Johnson on the right side
here's Johnson tried to cut in jablonsky down and
he stopped the rebound as Primo had a whack at it
from a face off the puck comes down in
the Canadian Zone and there's the 11th
goal of the the night for Detroit that equals the
all-time high against the Montreal
Canadians and they're still 656 to
go at the Detroit line return
pass rcky and Vernon with a
great stop off Mark Ry Eiserman
tied up by rine final 10 seconds
Eiserman circling One Last Shot doesn't get
through and that will do it the final visit
by the Detroit Red Wings to the Montreal Forum
and a night we won't soon forget well Patrick
W did something else that's uncharacteristic
normally I think the backup goenda goes out
onto the ice with the rest of the team but he
did not he went straight to the dressing room
right now he's in a race to see how quickly
he can get gear off and get out of here I'll
bet you I remember had bfor last year in
the playoffs after letting in a bad goal
in overtime in Chicago set the record I think he
was out of the building in 8 minutes before he met
anybody and maybe it was a good thing showered
or not I don't know but he was in civies I'll
tell you that that was after the Lum goal that's
right exactly the bad goal Chris and I remember
we went down at our normal Pace downstairs
and who's going out the door by everybody
at Belfor but he'd calmed down the next day and
he you know he talk to everybody this is little
[Applause]
different